should you buy the new m2 macbook air or
should you save a ton of money and go
for the m1 instead well today we will
find out because we are going to be
comparing everything with these laptops
from the design to the displays the
webcams the speakers we're going to be
skipping on some of our normal
benchmarks because people buy these
machines they're usually doing some
lighter tasks and focusing on how these
devices compare in the real world now
before i jump in i want to let you know
that we are giving away a brand new m2
macbook air and i don't care where you
are in the world i will pay for the
shipping any taxes or import fees and
we're going to give one of these to you
guys all i have to do is one be
subscribed to the channel and two
comment on these launch week videos
starting out with the one that came out
on friday you can comment once per video
and then on monday july 25th we will be
choosing a winner in one of our videos
so make sure you guys don't miss that
now right away i want to say that i
absolutely love the previous m1 macbook
air i love the design i love the
performance i love the price we highly
highly recommend this machine to so many
people specifically the base model with
the m2 i mean this is a beautiful
upgrade first off i love this color yes
you do get fingerprints on it and that
kind of sucks and yes you might be able
to have some more chipping or more
noticeable chipping because of this dark
color but it is gorgeous as far as the
footprint it is very similar
but the m2 is actually slightly
larger in footprint but with that we
have a reduction of about 20
in volume now this thing is extremely
thin overall and you guys see that it is
a slate design whereas the m1 version
has that iconic wedge shape that a lot
of us love now on the back it is
definitely thicker than the m2 macbook
air but on the front it does seem quite
a bit thinner just because of how the
bottom kind of curves in and it gives
you this illusion of thinness you guys
let me know which design you prefer down
in the comments section below the m2
also weighs less than the m1 even though
it has larger batteries inside it has a
very clean new layout that they did with
some nice upgrade options to repair
ability which is really cool to see in
our tear down video now we also did the
thermal fix video where we helped the
performance of this but we did take
those pads out just to make it a fair
comparison because most people won't be
doing that now one of my favorite things
about the m2 version of the macbook air
is magazine you get this nice braided
high quality cable and you get that
classic automatic connection right there
which just snaps in the magnets are
strong you get the led notification that
it's charging and then of course you get
full access to both of those thunderbolt
ports whereas with the m1 version if
you're in charging you only have one
unless you buy additional dongles or
docks i also really appreciate that the
m2 has fast charging where it can reach
50
in just 30 minutes with one of the 67
watt power adapters now that is a really
nice thing to have if you don't have it
charged up and you need to go now with
that on the other side both of them have
your headphone jack but the m2 can
support high impedance headphones so if
you do have a set that is nicer that
needs a little bit more juice it can
provide that opening these up what i
really miss is that macbook air logo on
the old one i think it'd be nice to have
it here but the new one has a clean
modern design both these do have touch
id to log in but the m2 has a larger one
along with full size function keys as
far as the keyboards the new one seems
to have slightly less key travel maybe
because it's thinner but with that the
keys are a little bit more springy
slightly louder and it gives a little
bit more feedback compared to the m1
macbook air which has more travel but
it's slightly mushier but of course
either way everybody will be happy with
these and with that the track pads are
both awesome the best in the industry
and now for the moment that i've been
waiting for the speakers our m1 macbook
air has these grilles on the side and we
have stereo speakers whereas on the m2
those grilles are missing the speakers
are actually built in at the top inside
and we have a few vents here when you
open it up where the sound can bounce up
at and off of the screen towards you
which is pretty cool and they're also
quad speakers with dedicated uh speakers
for the lower end so now let's go ahead
and take a listen
[Music]
me
oh the things that we do for thinness or
at least the apple does we were really
surprised by the findings here now one
thing you guys heard the difference
through a mono mic through youtube so
you guys let me know what differences
you heard but here it was pretty
substantial now the first thing that
stood out is the fact that it is quieter
it actually peaked at 80 decibels one
time but it averaged 77 to 78 whereas
the m1 version it peaked at 80 many
times and it would go to 78 and actually
just sitting at 79. so it is one to two
decibels louder now the next thing was
how wide the sound was here with the
speakers on the sides it felt like the
sound was kind of more all around me
where here with the m2 is very
noticeable the sound is coming from the
screen the speakers are closer together
and it's coming from one source it did
not sound as nice the highs are a little
bit more muted and as far as bass it is
a little bit better but a very small
difference so if i had to choose i would
go with the speakers on the m1 macbook
air and that is weird to say now as far
as the webcams and microphones the m1
uses the older 720p webcam and the
non-studio microphones the m2 version
has upgraded microphones and a 1080p
camera that should have more detail and
less noise and along with that with this
tough situation with that window there
it should have better hdr as well that
1080p webcam's larger sensor should also
help in low light situations if you're
in your house and your lights are dimmer
so you should have less noise compared
to the m1 macbook air with its much
older camera system and now let's talk
about the displays i love the one on the
m2 now yes there's a notch that does not
bother me it is worth the trade off
because we have this extra space here so
the menu bar isn't using any of that 16
by 10 display you guys can see we have
that large forehead there of wasted
space now with that we have thinner
bezels on the side and they're
completely even all around so it looks
nice we have a little bit more space the
m2 screen also gets brighter 500 nits
compared to 400 and it supports a
billion colors compared to 16.7 million
that part's not a huge difference you
just get better
gradients and both these are dci p3 so
if you care about having a great screen
the m2 is definitely better and now
let's get into real world performance
now we're going to start out with the
ssds i'm a bit sick of this topic but i
think it is unethical just not to
mention it so these base models the ssd
with this one gets
1372 right compared to
2221 on the m1 model as far as read
speeds we have 1446 on the m2 compared
to
2910 on the older m1 so yes it is more
than twice as fast now the next i'm
gonna do is transfer our folder of tests
that we do with these systems and we'll
see how that performs we'll test using
the same ssd and i'm going to start our
timer here so the m2 macbook air took 6
minutes and 30 seconds to transfer this
large folder full of files and the m1
macbook air took 3 minutes and 26
seconds being almost twice as fast now
you can easily fix this ssd issue but
it's going to cost you 200
to upgrade to the 512 and if you're
somebody that does transfer files and
you do different productivity tasks any
creative tasks we would highly suggest
to upgrade to that but with the m1 if
you don't care about the storage or you
do external even the base model will
give you really fast speeds now as far
as snappiness and using it for regular
things like web browsing both are going
to be super super fast the m2 is updated
so it is going to do a little bit better
as far as you know this web-based uh
browser test but in the real world
you're not gonna notice a difference
both are insanely good now a lot of
coders love the macbook air because it
is quick with this new apple silicon and
it's affordable so if you're a student
coding it is great so let's go ahead and
run our test project as we're compiling
one thing is noticeable that the m2
heats up way faster we're already at 107
108 which is a thermal limit here we're
at 74
now hitting 77
the m1 stays much cooler now we've done
the teardown we saw that metal kind of
foil piece that covered it up and what
somebody commented is that there is
actually a little piece of black kind of
tape that keeps heat in from going to
the bottom case
whereas the m1 it had a solid block of
metal
with a section that goes out that is
actually thicker so the m2 because it's
thinner apple changed the design they
have that little shielding which we
thought could be a vapor chamber it is
not and it definitely heats up quicker
the m2 air took two minutes and one
second compared to two minutes and 29
seconds for the m1 macbook air that
gives us a difference of 18
pretty much exactly what apple showed
off on stage so even if the m2 runs
hotter and throttles more ultimately for
coding it is faster now as far as music
production with logic we ran our test
right here and previously the m1 and the
pro would actually outperform the m2 is
a little bit more stable it can handle
more tracks but this time with the airs
we were able to handle 77 tracks on the
m2 and 75 tracks for the m1 and as far
as bouncing the files is the same so if
you're expecting to get better music
production with the m2
you are not going to get that it's going
to be about the same and now let's talk
about the graphics performance this is
one area where apple really hit it hard
during their event but the base model m2
does have an a core not the 10 core they
showed off and this macbook air has a 7
core it's a binned model and this is the
only one that they're selling now so we
are going to be using blender we're not
going to run some kind of a benchmark
and we are going to render this
classroom scene now as this is running
i'm noticing a couple things first off
the m2 is clearly ahead with its acore
graphics compared to the seven core as
far as temps they are really similar but
this task doesn't use all the
capabilities of the gpus even though we
are maxed out so these do not heat up as
much which is a good thing if you're
somebody that wants to do 3d rendering
and animations alright guys that is
finished and this is a pretty good
difference we have four minutes and 58
seconds for the m2
in 6 minutes and 24 seconds for the m1
with the 7 core that is a difference of
24
which is definitely substantial so when
we don't have any thermal throttling
with this task that is great and now for
all of you guys that do photo editing
out there we're going to test out adobe
lightroom classic as far as actual
editing it's going to be very similar as
long as your ssd isn't full on the m2
now this task does also use the graphics
along with the cpu it's been updated to
be faster let's go ahead and export 50
of these images and see what kind of
difference we get we're getting close to
the end here and it looks like the m1
macbook air is actually beating it out
now this uses the cpu and the gpu all of
that which the m2 should be faster but
it could be those ssds coming into play
the m1 did that in two minutes and nine
seconds compared to two minutes and 16
for the m2 so if you're going to be
doing tasks that do push both the cpu
and the gpu ram and ssd that is where
the m1 could be faster and for you guys
that want to do some video editing we
have final cut open up right here with a
simple 4k project with a couple effects
supply this is what most people do
especially those buying an m1 macbook
air as far as playback they're going to
be very similar where you're getting 72
gpu usage here compared to 70 over here
that means we have just a tiny bit more
gpu power left over for effects on the
m2 not much at all though i don't think
that's going to make a real world
difference now let's go ahead and export
this five minute project two minutes and
24 seconds for the m1 two minutes 22
seconds for the m2 now both these can be
good video editing machines if you're
doing some light work like this and if
you're working on other tasks let's say
for example prores raw footage for black
magic or anything else we will do some
more in-depth testing in our comparison
against the 14-inch macbook pro because
we think that is the next step up that
is actually worth it now as far as
battery life apple rates these the same
but the m2 does have some more powerful
efficiency cores so if you are doing
light work in real world mix tasks you
can actually get a little bit better
battery life but if you're going to be
cranking up the brightness you're going
to be hitting it the performance hard
especially on the cpu
then it should be about the same so
overall what is my opinion well i really
like the m2 macbook air i like the fact
that it's mac safe the redesign the
screen all those are really really nice
upgrades and if you're going to keep the
laptop for a long time you might
consider spending the extra money but i
would not buy it if you're trying to get
it for extra performance of the m2 chip
real world results for regular use it is
extremely similar so if you want to save
some money and you pick up one of these
for as low as 850 bucks or maybe even
under 800 bucks refurbished i would say
use the links down in the description
save yourself some money you will be
very happy with this laptop it was one
of the best out there before it is still
an absolutely great laptop especially
for that low price point but you guys
let me know your thoughts down below
click that circle above make sure you
comment down below to subscribe to win
one of these and check out those great
videos right over there this has been
max and i'll see you in the next video
[Music]